bonjour monsieur vous allez bien non ça
va très très bien merci gentil
parce que c'est trop cher Monsieur ah
oui vous êtes révolté là
la semaine dernière il y avait les
bonbons
55 trop d'abus trop d'abus on peut pas
vivre je sais pas comment on vit pas en
survie monsieur et là ça continue comme
ça en 2023 on va voir dans une galère
totale les gens ils vont trouver dehors
et les maisons ils arrivent même pas
payer le loyer les gens je sais pas
comment on va faire vivre sincèrement
moi je dis je sais pas comment on va
faire moi je voulais prendre ma retraite
il me donne 800 €, je travaille depuis
81 et en train de donner de l'argent à
l'Ukraine qu'est-ce qu'on en a pour de
l'Ukraine monsieur
dans la rue exactement alors on a aussi
rencontré un coup de personnes âgées qui
eux ont une vision assez spéciale de
l'inflation pour eux il y a aucun
problème regardez vous pensez que les
gens de l'argent et oui ah bon vous
voyez pas les gens n'empêche pas
d'acheter ça les empêche pas d'aller
jouer au tickets gratter
diverses choses si on recule en arrière
après la guerre les gens ont tiré la
langue oui on en a pas fait un cinéma
puis voilà mais du coup on peut vous
avez acheté quoi aujourd'hui vous bah
voilà
on peut voir bonjour madame vous allez
bien oui on va bien ça va alors bon vous
avez fait les courses sans regarder les
prix alors si on regarde les prix mon
mari c'est pas lui qui compte c'est moi
qui tient le budget vous vous êtes un
peu budget limité
vous êtes là pour vous faire que plaisir
quoi voilà c'est ça c'est madame qui
porte la culotte
c'est qui qui porte la culotte
merci d'être avec tous vos noms de
générateur 54 Olivier d'Auvergne
spécialiste de la grande distribution on
entend plein de choses actuellement et
on entend même des grands patrons de
grands enseignes qui dit que les prix
qui disent que les prix vont flamber
déjà sur un an l'inflation a atteint 5,2
% mais pour l'alimentaire la hausse est
encore plus forte 12 %. sachez le la
viande surgelé + 30 %. les pâtes plus
20%
les boîtes de conserve plus 18%. les
légumes frais plus 17%. les produits
laitiers plus 16% la volaille plus 13%
le café plus 11 % le pain et les
céréales + 10%, les produits animaliers
plus 41%
des comptes ou pas donc ça comment on
fait c'est effectivement très dur ça va
continuer ou pas oui ça va continuer
parce que les négociations commerciales
qui sont en cours en ce moment entre les
grandes marques et les grandes
distributeurs c'est le moment où
traditionnellement on explique que c'est
la guerre qui se qui se mettent les les
uns sur les autres et bien ça va se
traduire à partir du mois de mars
lorsque les nouveaux tarifs
s'appliqueront en magasin parce que j'ai
appelé déjà depuis quelques semaines un
mars rouge ou un mars sanglant parce que
il va y avoir sur un laps de temps très
court une inflation aussi forte que
celle qu'on a connu l'année dernière sur
9 mois donc elle va pas être plus
importante que les 12 %, c'est juste que
le sentiment la perception sera plus
élevée parce que ça va se jouer sur un
temps beaucoup plus court en gros entre
les quatre à six semaines le temps que
les nouveaux tarifs descendent dans les
magasins on aura les conséquences de
négociations qui sont en cours voilà
alors c'est quoi ces histoires de
négociation c'est la loi qui oblige en
fait les qui oblige les marques et les
distributeurs en négocier tous les ans
en gros pour faire simple entre décembre
et fin février pour que le 1er mars il y
a les nouveaux tarifs de l'année en
cours qui s'applique voilà et donc si
c'est pas fini au 28 février de cette
année hors-la-loi donc c'est la loi qui
organise ça on peut la trouver bien pas
bien est-ce que ça en fait est-ce que
c'est l'actualité voilà
des moments qui fait que les prix
flambes oui c'est il y a des conseils
enfin il y a malheureusement
pris voilà 20% encore 20% oui et elles
avaient déjà pris de toute façon 30 %
l'année d'avance c'est-à-dire aurait
fait Ukraine les pâtes avaient déjà
progressé en 2021 parce qu'il y a eu une
récolte de blé dur pour faire des pâtes
il faut du blé dur qui était mauvaise
notamment au Canada et ça avait peser
sur les coups en fait malheureusement il
y a des raisons objectives à la hausse
des prix vous avez la hausse des
matières premières mécaniquement il faut
il faut d'ailleurs savoir ce que l'on
veut quand on veut que les paysans
vivent mieux on veut qu'ils gagnent
mieux leur vie donc effectivement ça se
traduit jusqu'au consommateur
deuxièmement vous avez le coût de
l'énergie que l'on vit tous
l'alimentation c'est très énergivore on
s'en rend pas compte mais quand on mange
quelque chose on mange de l'énergie il a
fallu préparer le produit le couper le
transformer le stériliser le surgelé peu
importe les mots ça ça prend de
l'énergie et puis enfin il faut le
transporter et malheureusement là aussi
ben il y a des coûts supplémentaires
sans compter que pour faire tout ça il
faut des hommes et même si c'est jamais
assez les salaires ont déjà augmenté en
2022 ils ont continué au 1er janvier et
donc en bout de chaîne c'est toujours le
consommateur qui paye toujours toujours
quels sont les produits qui vont être
les plus touchés les produits qui vont
être les plus touchés sont les produits
sur lesquels la composante énergétique
est très forte par exemple tout ce qui
est cuit recuit les biscuits par exemple
comme son nom l'indique quand on dit
biscuit c'est parce que c'est cuit
plusieurs fois bon voilà mais je suis
venu pour vous apprendre des trucs
plus que des carottes râpées bon voilà
petit biscuits c'est le chanteur en fait
voilà
c'est fort hein
progresser bien sûr et donc les produits
sont très inflammés parce que ça c'est
très cher ils s'en fout il aime pas les
animaux
très très chauffés et donc mécaniquement
ça évidemment ça fera mais pourquoi
alors alors pourquoi les pâtes ça
augmente là parce que dans les pâtes
c'est pas chauffé mais si bien sûr
ma mère maman je vais cueillir des pâtes
un peu plus compliqué que ça mais il
faut notamment payer le blé qui a
augmenté il faut payer le transport il
faut payer l'usine quand vous fabriquez
des pâtes vous consommez de l'énergie ne
serait-ce que quand vous mélangez de
l'eau et du blé de la farine ça vous
prend de l'énergie donc malheureusement
c'est là où aujourd'hui on se rend
compte à quel point dans nos assiettes
il y a des produits agricoles et de
l'énergie jusqu'à présent on avait
commencé avec que des produits
exactement
Antoine vous êtes association de
consommateurs famille de France de
nombreuses familles se retrouvent dans
des situations compliquées parce que le
panier moyen il augmente alors nous
d'après notre analyse parce que il
parlait d'un mars sanglot tout alors je
vais pas m'appuyer d'entrer sur le mars
sanglant mais je vais rebondir
immédiatement sur ce que vous venez
l'évoquer un panier moyen on estime
qu'avant cette période de forte
inflation que l'on est en train de
connaître c'était à peu près 85 euros
aujourd'hui pour qu'on sait c'est pour
retenir un panier moyen exactement alors
il faut relire pour une semaine alors à
peu près une semaine etc relativiser la
statistique parce que c'est normal pour
certains c'est 85 € mais si vous avez
bien évidemment une famille nombreuse
plus élevé aujourd'hui on est pas aux
alentours de 100 euros alors 15 euros ça
peut paraître énorme mais la fin du mois
c'est énorme on découvre à la fin du
mois 400 balles au lieu de bah
que des enfants faut vraiment
m'expliquer ce que tu mets dans le
panier à ça
là il nous fait nous donne les chiffres
voilà
et est-ce que juste si je peux me
permettre de répondre à vraiment parce
que la remarque est extrêmement juste
encore une fois un panier moyen par
définition c'est une moyenne entre une
famille qui par exemple va être composée
de deux personnes ou inversement s'il y
a quatre personnes s'il y a 6 personnes
vous êtes sur un niveau de prix qui va
être beaucoup plus élevé donc c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'il faut bien
relativiser ce on prend 85 euros 100
euros en 2022 et maintenant on est sur
cette base a priori de 100 euros donc 15
euros d'écart mais c'est une moyenne qui
faut relativiser les écarts peuvent être
beaucoup plus importants juste on va en
parler pourquoi la nourriture pour chien
pour chat à flamber comme ça c'est plus
c'est ce qu'elle peut tomber l'énergie
parce que c'est très énergivore parce
que quand vous préparez de la nourriture
pour animaux vous la vous la chauffer
vous la surchauffez et notamment ben
voilà cette composante énergétique elle
est ça va continuer ça bah l'énergie ça
dépend ni de vous ni de moins ni de nous
là on subit le marché mondial et on se
réveille donc ça va pas s'améliorer donc
bah la probabilité que la situation
géopolitique qui est à la base de la
situation énergétique s'améliore elle
est quand même faible pour le coup il y
a des experts en militaires plus avisés
que moi là-dessus alors est-ce que les
les Français qui font plus attention
aujourd'hui
bien sûr bien sûr les Français font plus
attention en tout cas nous au sein de
famille de France au sein de notre
réseau on a chaque semaine des
consommateurs des familles qui nous
disent mais au début on s'en sortait
parce que on avait qu'une inflation qui
était j'ai envie de dire sectorielle
c'était que l'énergie c'était que
l'essence mais on a commencé à avoir ce
cumul sur l'alimentaire vient se
rajouter par dessus et quand on a des
gens qui nous disent je suis obligé de
me priver finalement je donne je mange
pas à ma faim pour pouvoir nourrir mes
enfants c'est un constat qui est
terrible et pour nous en tant qu'acteur
dans le milieu associatif on est je
dirais vecteur vecteur voilà de
certaines d'une certaine forme de valeur
de solidarité et on estime
qu'aujourd'hui la solidarité elle doit
peser sur tout le monde le gouvernement
il est au travail nous on ne fait pas de
politique mais on a la chance d'être
reçus par les pouvoirs publics
fréquemment donc on porte ce message
mais en estime aussi que les industriels
les distributeurs les producteurs ils
doivent faire part de responsabilité
parce que c'est un effort collectif qui
doit être porté alors on va vous dire
dans un instant aussi quel produit pour
une banquier dans les supermarchés en
2023 on va en parler avec nos invités
mais juste il y a Léna vous êtes mère de
famille on parlait du pouvoir d'achat
vous êtes maman de trois enfants
et on retrouva devoir faire toujours
plus attention à la moindre dépense la
salle augmentation des prix vous la
sentez vous la voyez très nettement là
complètement donc vous rendez compte en
mars si elle la voit déjà maintenant
c'est pour ça que je suis à 5 lettres là
quand j'entends ça pour vous expliquer
un peu ma situation donc avec mon mari
lui accumule deux emplois d'accord pour
essayer à la fin du mois d'être moins
découvert que les mois d'avant
on réfléchit toujours aux courses qu'on
fait pour vous donner les exemples là
j'ai fait mon panier de fruits et
légumes tout à l'heure j'ai pas acheté
de courgettes parce que à 1 euro 17 la
courgette quand on est cinq
il en faut de la courgette donc j'en
achète pas le brocoli ou le qui soit un
euro bah il est à 1,92
ça fait un gros panier le poisson je
n'achète plus de poissons
je suis à centre maternelle donc j'en
achète pour les enfants que j'accueille
mais pour mes profs enfants j'en achète
plus je dois choisir entre poisson et la
viande
la viande vous avez des vous avez des
façons de faire les courses qui peuvent
vous aider je rebondis sur votre argent
pour noter les spectateurs sur la
courgette vous dites que vous l'avez vu
et si vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu bien
évidemment vous l'avez vu un euro 17
vous étiez dans quel magasin ou dans
quel dans quel enseigne c'est vrai que
je commande sur une application
s'appelle je peux citer le nom de
l'application
mes fruits et légumes parce que c'est
compliqué dans mon organisation
personnelle d'aller faire les courses un
peu plus cher donc c'est un peu plus
cher avec Leclerc par exemple
la courgette elle est elle est à 1,05 si
vous achetez de la courgette la
courgette pardon surgelée chez Leclerc
c'est 1,34 aujourd'hui si vous voulez
vérifier parce que c'est un peu mon
métier de connaître les prix vous
vérifiez vous allez voir un euro 34 le
kilo et on voyait quand vous l'achetez
surgelé en plus vous avez pas de déchets
elle est préparée et donc en fait il
faut aussi peut-être regarder
différemment sa relation en cours on
mange mal en fait
après ce que chacun son assiette il y a
pas de jugement à avoir chacun fait
comme il veut moi je juge personne mais
moi je veux juste vous sensibiliser au
fait que à la façon de faire les courses
on peut peut-être arbitrer différemment
pour être moins victime de l'inflation
il s'agit pas de dire qu'il y a pas
d'inflation moi je vous ai dit pour
démarrer que ça allait même être encore
fort donc je suis pas là pour dire qu'il
y a pas mais voyez sur certaines grammes
de la de la courgette parce que je
trouve que je le connais bah si vous les
achetez surgelés ça va vous coûter cher
Leclerc un euro 34 et dans les enseignes
les moins compétitifs ça va être 1 € 50
le kilo vous voyez on est loin d'une
courgette je suis d'accord avec vous
après faut voir au goût aussi de la
courgette surgelée enfin moi en tout cas
personnellement dans ma vie de famille
je favorise plutôt le frais et le fait
maison quand je fais avec de la
courgette ne serait-ce que d'autres
magasins
mais pour être totalement factuel il n'y
a pas plus frais que des légumes
surgelés alors parce qu'ils ont été
récoltés à maturité
transformer à maturité et surgelés
immédiatement le risque dans les
courgettes qu'on achète en magasin et
d'ailleurs on le voit à l'oeil parfois
vous devez les voir flétri toutes sèches
toutes desséchés
de la surgelée de très très loin de très
très loin elle est moins cher et elle
est même si c'est paradoxal contre
intuitif plus fraîche comment parce que
parfois c'est vrai qu'on la voit
ce que c'est là-dessus
Daniel on a vu des courgettes
s'il vous plaît alors quel produit
pourrait manquer dans les supermarchés
en 2023 puisque en plus de la hausse des
prix des consommateurs pourraient faire
face à un autre problème cette année
dans les supermarchés certains produits
pourraient manquer la viande rouge je
crois alors on est en plutôt en déficit
de production de viande de bœuf c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les steaks hachés
surgelés sont parmi les produits qui ont
le plus augmentés la loi de l'offre et
de la demande malheureusement donc là en
fait on est victime du foot que les il y
a moins de vaches en France tout
simplement parce qu'il y a moins
d'éleveurs laitiers parce que comme il
gagnait pas bien leur vie pendant des
années bien sûr donc c'est un cercle qui
n'est pas vertueux mais qui est vicieux
donc la viande oui bien sûr donc non
seulement plus cher mais en plus moins
facilement disponible le riz pourquoi le
riz parce que
c'est parti en Suisse
un peu médiatique il a suffi à peu près
deux mois de cela vous en rappelez
peut-être qu'on évoque qui avait des
menaces sur les récoltes en Asie du
Sud-Est pour que automatiquement on est
on a acheté chacun d'entre nous un
paquet de plus que ce qu'on a acheté
c'est ça notre échelle sauf que si tout
le monde fait un paquet de plus ça
double du le lendemain tout ce qui est
vendu c'est ce qu'on appelle une
prophétie auto-réalisatrice vous y
croyez pas à la pénurie sauf que moi
j'en ai acheté lui aussi lui aussi etc
etc donc vous allez voir que le rayon se
vide vous n'y croyez pas à ce moment-là
mais vous finissez par y croire donc
vous prenez le dernier paquet et il y a
pénurie c'est-à-dire que c'est cette
espèce boule de neige et voilà c'est
assez menace sur la récolte il y avait
pas une menace avérée bon voilà c'est un
peu ce qu'on avait connu l'année
dernière sur l'île de tournesol au tout
début alors le gars de lui de tournesol
dans toutes les caves et tous les
placards des Français en avant l'huile
ça a augmenté de fou aussi de l'huile
bien sûr l'offre et la demande quand on
en trouvait plus il y a des gens qui se
sont fait une spécialité d'aller en
acheter à l'étranger dans des filières
qu'on connaissait pas mais qui ont
revendu ça le prix de la cocaïne
puisqu'ils étaient les seuls à en avoir
des bouteilles il y a tué
mais c'était à peu près ça vous savez
l'huile de tournesol premier prix il va
aller 1 € 59 il y a un an la guerre
n'avait pas été n'avait pas été déclarée
aujourd'hui l'huile de tournesol premier
prix je parle pas des grandes marques
elles vont 3,50 € plus de deux fois plus
cher c'est incroyable c'est la loi de de
la demande mais personne n'en achète à
ce prix mais ma mère qui met une
bouteille d'huile par repas
alors le pain c'est à cause de
l'approvisionnement oblique qui est
perturbé par la guerre en Ukraine ben
l'Ukraine est un gros pays c'est réalisé
un gros pays agricole et donc
mécaniquement non seulement ça rend les
céréales moins facilement disponibles
rappelez-vous il a fallu que sous
l'égide de l'ONU il y a des bateaux qui
puissent traverser je sais plus quel
Détroit avec des militaires autour
devant à côté pour que ça passe donc
mécaniquement chaque fois qu'il y a des
tensions d'approvisionnement ça fait
monter les prix et quand ça fait monter
les prix ça rend le produit moins
disponible et malheureusement pour nous
encore une fois en bout de chaîne le
pain plus cher le pain aujourd'hui une
baguette normale elle vaut 1 euro à 1
euro 20 alors que c'était 20 centimes de
moins il y a encore il y a encore
quelques mois et il y a les pois chiches
aussi pourquoi alors je suis pas assez
expert fois chiche mais ça je vais vous
laisser je vais demander à un pote à moi
justement il y a des conseils aussi
parce que vous nous dites que en mars
vous appelez ça le le mars le mars rouge
vraiment c'est dire quoi ça veut dire
que là on va ça veut dire quoi un panier
à 50 euros ça va être quoi ça va être
plus doux ah non non non non parce qu'il
faut relativiser ça veut dire que on a
chacun des exemples où on a vu des
doublement de prix bien évidemment on en
a tous moins j'en ai aussi vous en avez
on en a tous bon mais la moyenne elle
est que à 10 12 13 15%. c'est énorme
15% d'accord quand même voilà et donc on
aura probablement sur les quatre à six
semaines qui vont démarrer à partir du
1er mars à peu près le même niveau d'un
Flac d'inflation je vous le redis que ce
qu'on a eu en dernier
le principe de l'inflation c'est que
voilà ça fera au final sur un an et
quelques mois ben on sera à plus de 20%,
ça c'est une certitude c'est une
certitude mais ça nous oblige aussi
peut-être à reprioriser une partie de
nos dépenses on en peut plus de repris
prioriser les Français
on n'est pas là pour faire un débat on
n'est pas là pour on va pas prioriser
encore les dépenses alors juste Antoine
les conseils pour consommer moins cher
déjà il faut pas faire vos courses avec
la fin au ventre c'est qui oui alors
c'est un conseil presque déplorable
malheureusement mais nous nous l'une des
techniques qui est pour je vais rien
vous révéler d'exceptionnel c'était de
s'orienter vers les produits premier
prix sauf que le souci qu'on a eu le
premier c'est au niveau de la qualité on
sait que c'est parfois des produits qui
sont moins de bonne qualité et surtout
même les produits qui sont qualifiés de
premier prix à la base on se rend compte
quand on est en difficulté parce que ce
sont aussi des produits dont les coûts
de production ont explosé et comme par
définition ce sont des produits qui à la
base sont déjà tirés au plus bas parce
que vous n'avez pas de coût annexe comme
les coûts publicitaires ou les coups de
marketing dès lors que l'inflation est
partie sur la matière première bah
forcément même les produits premier prix
pour le coup ils sont en pleine
expansion ils sont en pleine
augmentation donc au final on commence
presque en matière alimentaire à manquer
très clairement d'astuces une des une
des techniques et encore une fois je
vais la assez principalement à
l'ensemble des consommateurs et
notamment ceux à ceux qui sont à la
campagne où vous avez une possibilité de
circuit court qui peut être plus
intéressante vous avez des initiatives
locales la Fédération nationale des
Familles de France le met en avant
systématiquement avec notamment la
possibilité de panier de fruits et
légumes à 1 € par exemple c'est des
petites astuces encore une fois mais on
sent bien qu'on manque très clairement
de marge de manœuvre juste vous avez
parlé donc mars ça va on va on va subir
une augmentation similaire en un mois à
ce qu'on a subi en augmentation en un an
ça va durer combien de temps cette
mascarade ça va durer probablement
jusqu'à l'été parce que après l'été on
n'a pas de vision si notamment les
matières premières pourraient rebaisser
on va prendre mais minimum l'été ah ben
bien sûr parce que bien sûr l'énergie à
moyen terme on la voit pas baisser les
matières premières à moyen terme on les
voit pas baisser ça pourrait baisser dès
lors qu'il y ait plus de tension
géopolitique les cours du gaz du pétrole
de l'électricité enfin les prix vont
baisser sur les céréales ça serait
pareil donc le principe des matières
premières c'est que ces cyclique ça va
ça vient là ce qui nous pose problème
c'est qu'on a non seulement le cycle des
matières premières plus tout le reste
alors qu'en général on avait que les
matières premières donc on pouvait faire
une forme d'amortisseur mais en gros moi
je les trois conseils que l'on peut
donner c'est un d'abord il faut aller
dans les enseignes qui sont les moins
chers ces bananes oui mais il faut le
rappeler ça veut dire qu'il y a des
enseignes qui ont des indices de prix
qui sont parfois les anciennes qui sont
les moins chères en fait le problème
qu'il y a c'est que parfois les
anciennes qui sont les moins chères
elles sont très loin c'est beaucoup plus
loin donc il faut prendre la voiture
aujourd'hui avec le prix de l'essence tu
fais même ton calcul à l'arrivée tu as
dépensé plus d'essence pour y aller et
c'est ça les gens sont dans des calculs
voilà même des séances de trucs voilà
donc ça c'est ça c'est aussi un souci
parce que c'est un peu loin mais voyez
par exemple dans la façon d'acheter des
galets vous vous faites livrer ben vous
allez payer une part du service même si
le même s'il y a marqué livraison
gratuite parce que la livraison gratuite
ça n'existe pas dans l'économie c'est
dans les prix d'envoyer il y a peut-être
aussi une fête de repenser sa façon d'A
après il faut savoir que je l'ai déjà
repensé parce qu'avant ça j'allais
directement au marché j'en avais pour 30
euros de plus ouais bien sûr donc j'ai
déjà repensé ma façon de faire et là je
ne sais je ne sais sur le fond quand
vous vous faites livrer il faut bien il
faut bien comprendre et bien savoir que
vous payez et c'est normal vous payez le
livreur qui vous le livre et celui qui a
préparé votre commande alors que si vous
allez au supermarché par principe vous
le faites bénévolement tu vois c'est
quoi le troisième conseil c'est ce qu'on
appelle la descente en gamme
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des produits sur
lesquels acheter la grande marque
indispensable la marque de distribution
ça peut être ça après vous impactez des
petits collégiens et des petits copains
des écoliers mais des grands collégiens
c'est c'est symboliquement trop fort et
donc pour des enfants par exemple si
vous leur donnez pas leur granola ils
vont faire la gueule alors que moi et
moi ma mère elle a acheté voilà j'ai
acheté des des des des petits collégiens
c'est pas des petits écoliers non mais
c'est vrai vous êtes des économies bien
sûr
ce qu'on appelle la je sais pas du Galam
alors on peut le voir non mais on peut
le voir comme une punition mais on peut
le voir aussi comme une astuce
mais tu crois quoi on mange
il faut la faire venir pour qu'elle
donne ses conseils moi j'ai pas des tucs
j'ai des tac tac tac